sue is with us Sue's in California hi
Sue welcome to your welcome today Ramsay
show how can we help
well we owned on my business partner and
I own a small business meal actually -
dance studio location and it's super
frustrating here in California since
there seems to be more focus on
gathering data than getting businesses
back on their feet and we've listened
and have educated ourselves immensely in
the last several weeks with strategies
and ways to stay afloat but small
businesses here I don't know about the
rest of the country but weren't even
given an opportunity to keep doing what
they were doing and incorporate the
directives and I know that they're
offering loans but we know that that's
just a temporary fix and I'm just to the
point where I want to know like my civil
liberties are being taken from us our
freedoms are being taken from us they're
not giving us really any definitive
dates
I want to go back to work and I want to
open up my business and I want to I will
implement those mandates that essential
businesses apparently had that
opportunity to do but we were not given
that opportunity so I just want some
advice on that because sue can I ask you
so how what is your main form of Revenue
is it classes where there's larger
groups or is it also individual dance
lessons it's large its we particularly
we are a recreational studio we do have
a performance team company but we're
predominantly a recreational and so
classroom instruction in-person
instruction so we've done everything
we've pivoted we're online we we are
pre-recorded we have live zoom classes
but it is not the preferred method of
service and we survived our first April
months because we are on an automatic
tuition and invoicing system sir I asked
you when I understand preferred method
in terms of format and and what's best
for the students how is this impacted
revenue has the pivot that you guys made
I've been able to keep you guys afloat
from a cash flow standpoint well they
were that auto drugs for April so it'll
be may for you know right yeah me well
April was we survived but may is not
looking favorable because we keep having
news daily allegedly these daily updates
with no specific information I mean
which city are UN we're in San Diego and
so our county isn't anywhere near what
Los Angeles County and San Francisco
area in with regards to you know I mean
I and I could go on and on because I
just personally feel I spoke with my own
doctor to find out specific information
about this because this virus because we
need to make good business decisions
that are going to keep our staff and our
customers healthy and his information
does not align with the with the
direction of the leadership here you
know I was trying to explain that to a
person in government I was having a
discussion with earlier in the week that
the that the problem is that those of us
that are entrepreneurial running our own
businesses you have to present credible
data to us and if our data was off as
far as their data has been we would have
been out of business a long time ago oh
my gosh and if I had someone working for
me whose data model was as far off I
would give them one pass and then I
would fire them for incompetence and I
was trying to explain that the
government you cannot cast a vision for
people people are not going to stay in
their homes because they no longer
believe the data because it's been so
inconsistent and the models and the
application of the restrictions have
been
so willy-nilly and so inconsistent and
so even yeah you're I think a lot of us
share your your frustrations know well
and this is what frustrates me I we sit
in these webinars and all of these
entrepreneurs are like well what can we
do what we do and I said okay well we're
doing what we need to be doing but we
also need to be smart and we can use our
voices and say this information is not
lining up so it doesn't you me
collectively come together and say I if
is the data and it's the information
that came from my position lined up I
would I'm all-in
exactly so I'm just go throw something
at you real quick here because I'm with
you I'm so frustrated on your behalf
right now but I think you do have to
make your voice heard here's what I
would do if I were you this is worth a
stab number one I talk to your clients
talk to these people their kids or maybe
these are adults that are paying for
your services or have up to this point
if they got tested have they been tested
are they willing to get tested and if
they had a negative test or they got
positive than they quarantine for 14
days whatever the CDC says would they be
willing to come in if you had all of the
safety things in place and everybody was
tested we're already seeing multiple
states around the country agreeing to
open up if you took their temperature
before they came in if you went to all
these F degrees I think if you have
clients who said they'll come in I think
you got to make that case I'd sign a
petition and I'd take it to the mayor
I'd take it to the to the city you have
to do it and I would publish it to I put
the word out I think at this point you
have to I think the you have to spread
the word this is where the protester
coming I think you there's anger they're
not crazy no rotational and it has shut
down dreamers and law jobs they're
logically looking at the data that
doesn't line up it's not consistent
and they're just not gonna stay home
anymore